all right
greetings all right well our next
session hey hey Bert greetings
great how are you doing good good very
well
um our next session is with bird device
Dimitri bagayev and Bart van Erp it's
going to be called towards user-friendly
design of synthetic active inference
agents and I know a lot of people are
super excited to see this really
practical and Cutting Edge work so to
you Bert and just let us know how we can
support
okay great uh well is my audio good yep
sounds good okay then I'm gonna share my
screen uh
I hope I picked the right one I don't
work it's Zoom quite often looks good it
looks good yep all right super
um well thanks a lot to Daniel for for
hosting this uh Symposium I've been
watching some talks it's really amazing
and uh we really we feel privileged to
get the chance to present ourselves so
we are also just like a few others
before is interested in developing a
toolbox for active inference
and so this picture or it kind of shows
what we're
um what we're about or what we're
interested in so here's a lady on the
left hand side and
um we're gonna
try to get a laser pointer and she has
this idea about a rewarding behavior for
a vacuum cleaning robot right so she's
writing down she has a textual
expression but move around the apartment
apply suction until the floor is clean
do not touch objects and when don't
return to the dog so that that's not so
hard I'm gonna rate that with one star
out of three stars in terms of difficult
difficulty level to specify that
but that's not enough to program these
robots right because what she really
needs to do now is to specify a
generative model and uh that you know
the there is effectors and actuators
right the robot has to move around apply
suction until the floor is clean so the
sensors probably a camera do not touch
objects so maybe there has to be object
recognition this is a really difficult
task to come up with this generative
model here and on top of that
she has to specify this kind of
rewarding behavior in terms now of
probability distributions of this
generative model so very difficult I'm
going to rate that with two stars
because
the next thing she has to do for this
model is to specify the inference
procedure to do actually active
inference and freelanci minimization in
real time
or this complex model and really that's
almost impossible right only a few
Specialists can really write a procedure
for for variational free energy
minimization in some very difficult
model so what we are about what we've
been working on is to try to automate
the inference task so get rid of the
three stars and yes she will still have
to specify her model but in the long
term we try to get away from that so in
the long term we hope we will get a
toolbox and now we're talking five ten
years right where a textual description
would be enough to specify some initial
model with an initial prior and
everything else is just automated
inference learning of States parameters
structural adaptation of the model even
maybe based on her feedback updating uh
the the prior so that's long term uh for
now we would be very happy if we could
just automate the inference uh task so
um why why is it so difficult to specify
inference for an active inference agents
well we have so many competing
kpis right we we uh we want to do this
for large model Scopes not just for ABCD
models but maybe there's also continuous
variables and
biological models right must be very
user friendly you really don't want her
to worry about robustness of her code
um we don't want her to worry about
whether
um two variables are have coinji good
relationships right
um adaptivity we want to update States
parameters maybe even the model the
model structure has to be low power
because these angels often run on edge
devices all right so they run on their
battery powered has to be in real time
because you can't learn how to ride a
bike if there's no real-time reasoning
and on top of that you actually want to
minimize variation of reality right you
want to do it at least as good or at
least in a neighborhood of if you would
do a manual derivation and some of these
this is a rather bite each other right
if you uh you want to minimize
variational free energy but you have to
do it in real time and on low power yeah
that kind of bites each other right so
these are
difficult kpis that we we want to yeah
we they're all important you can't just
take one out
um because then the whole system
wouldn't work
um so
um when you read papers on active
inference you often also read and now we
Implement variation variety minimization
and that can be done by message passing
on a graph and I want to clarify first
why it has to be done by message passing
on the graph
um I'll do that by giving a very short
answer
and then do an example the short answer
is that Bayesian inference involves
um Computing very large sum of products
like what you see here on the left hand
side here's a product AC
adbc and then we send them in AC plus 80
and so forth this is a sum of products
now we know by the distributive law that
this here on the left hand side can also
be computed as on the right hand side If
I multiply this out I get a times C plus
a times D and so forth this is a product
of sums and there
exactly the same thing the only
difference is that to compute the left
hand side takes four additions sorry
four multiplications and three additions
to compute the right hand side takes two
additions and one only one
multiplication so on the right hand side
is much cheaper to compute in the left
hand side normally when we write down
marginalization and the Asian inference
we we write things down in the as in the
left hand side what message passing does
on the graph it will automatically
convert that into much deeper to
evaluate product of sums and I'll give
an example of that
um
so here is an uh an example Model F of
seven variables X1 X2 through X7 and
this model happens to be factorized F A
of X1 fbx2 and so forth now we can draw
this factorization in a as a graph
and what we do and this is called a
Forney style Factor graph what we do is
for each factor F A we allocate a node
so FB gets a note and FC gets a note
and we associate the variables in our
system with the edge and an edge is
connected to a node if that variable is
an argument of that function so FC is a
function of F of X1 X2 X 3 and that
means that FC connects to the edges X1
X2 X3 and FD is only a function of X4 so
if D only connects to the edge X4 so
what you can see in this graph is this
graph is nothing but
a visualization of the factorization
assumptions that we have for this model
now if I'm interested in a big
marginalization a task integrate out
over all variables but X3 so X1 X2 X4
and so forth through X7 I'm interested
in this
um then
making taking advantage of this
factorization I can rewrite this sum
this basically this sum of product into
a product of sums as as below here what
you will see here below this computes
exactly the same thing but I've made use
of this distributive law for instance
FC contains no X4 no X5 so I moved it
over the summation sign to the left and
FB also doesn't contain X4 X5 x67 so I
moved it all the way to the left
and when you do that you are left here
with an expression
where I only some some over two two
variables and here I have to sum over
six variables and here over two and here
over two so you can imagine if each
variable let's say so X1 X2 if each
variable has 10 interesting values that
you need to sum over
then I have here
the original marginalization problem I
have 10 to the power 6 so a million
terms and here
in red I have 100 terms and here I have
100 and here I have 100 so here I have
300 terms and here I have 1 million
terms so is it it's an enormous
reduction in computational
complexity
when we make use of this distributive
law now it turns out that if you write
this out you can associate these these
intermediate factors with messages on
the graph it's just an interpretation a
visual interpretation it's as if
FC
receives a message from fa and FB
receive or FC receives the message from
X from FB and computes an outgoing
message mu X3 and the same thing for Fe
so Fe receives a message from a
neighboring factors FD and FF and
computes an outgoing message
or X3 so what you see here is that the
entire marginalization process can be
represented as basically Computing a few
messages on a graph
and multiplying some of these messages
with each other and and and and that's
how you can do base in inference and
also how you can do variational free
energy minimization so this works in
um in factorized models but I would say
even stronger if your model is not
factorized and you have a lot of
variables uh there is just no way you
can do proper inference so any serious
model is factorized like the brain is
almost sparse is is almost empty we have
well is it about 10 billion neurons and
each neuron connects to a few thousand
other neurons so if I would draw the
graph that graph is almost empty it is
hugely sparse and so there is no other
way to do inference in the brain than by
message passing
um so that's why message passing just
because it's more effective than
anything else
now then the issue is which message do
you compute how do you compute messages
um because there are different ways of
doing it right and we also read in
active inference papers you can do this
by variational message passing or
expectation maximization or belief
propagation and
variational LaPlace and all these terms
turns out that there is a an umbrella
framework for all these methods passing
Frameworks and that umbrella framework
is called constraint better
free energy minimization and I try I
will try to
illustrate that by uh well by this slide
so here I have this graph this is just
an example graph
where my generative model is basically
factorizing F A FB FC of dnfe and I've
also written that here so this now is
the variation of free energy
now I haven't made any assumption on Q
of X so Q of X is still Q of X1 X2 X3 is
just a joint overall variables and it
doesn't have any factorization
assumption
um it makes sense to also assume that
the posterior kind of follows the
factorization Assumption of the prior
namely of the generative model so if we
make that assumption
and that means we're going to make the
assumption that Q X is also now a
product of qas
of X of a where qas of X of a stands for
beliefs over notes what I mean by that
is that Q of B is a is a posterior
belief over this node meaning it's a
posterior belief over the edges that
connect to these nodes just like FB is a
function of X1 X2 X
4 that's if you will the prior or the
generative model then Q of B the
variational posterior for this node will
also depend on X1 X2 X4 and on no other
factors if you just do that then you
will count some of the variables double
because X1 is part of the belief over F
A but also part of the belief over FB so
we just have to Discount that by
dividing by beliefs over edges that
means that I make now an assumption
that my posterior believes is
is is divided into local beliefs over
notes and local beliefs over edges over
variables
this will make things a lot simpler in
fact if my graph is a tree and it is a
tree here and I would do message passing
on that tree and I could suppose I could
do that perfectly everything is linear
gaussian then I get perfect Bayesian
inference there is no approximation so
this is a good assumption sometimes it's
still very hard to compute a message
because
even the the the the the single message
that come out of these nodes the still
integrals or summations and in
particular the integrals may be a
problem we may not have an analytical
answer so what we sometimes do is add
additional
um assumptions we'll say well the
posterior belief over FD I can't compute
it in general
but I'm gonna just assume now that it's
a gaussian that makes it easier or we
can make an extra factorization
assumption
and say the posterior belief over FB
which is really a belief over the joint
X1 X2 X4 is going to be broken into
uh um independent belief over X1 and in
the belief over
um X2 and X4
um
these additional assumptions if I impose
them as well this is what I will call
now if I if I if I all substituted here
in Q of X I get what's called a
constrained beta-free energy this is the
same death as in the Oppenheimer movie
this is Hans beta where it's named after
and
um so
we have a graph now
that that is highly factorized and we
have
local beliefs over notes and over
um over edges and they're indicated with
with red and we have additional
constraints in green there could be
gaussians or mean field constraints or
other constraints and now we will assume
constraint that make it possible to
compute all the messages and now we can
just automate this by making different
assumptions we can turn this into
expectation maximization or belief
propagation or
um
hybrid forms are off we can turn it into
any relevant message passing algorithm
that you've heard of so this is a very
nice umbrella framework that basically
encompasses everything and and there is
a we've written a pretty large paper
on this
um in the in entropy Journal where you
can read all the math on how this works
so we've talked about why message
passing namely because it's the most
effective way of doing it inference and
we've talked about which messages to
compute namely
we turn our
variational free energy into something
called a constrained better free energy
and then we can compute messages the
only thing that's left is well when do
we pass these messages right what is the
sequence of messages which one comes
first
and
um this is where we see a lot of papers
right
um
you have the right control flow what's
good control flow you have to say okay
here is my algorithm for active
inference first I specify a model then
let's do inference for every time step
collect a new observation update the
state update the desired future
right and so forth compute expected free
energy select the policy Etc
um this kind of program the problem with
active inferences is that there is
nested for Loops in here here's a for
Loop and here's another for Loop and for
each of these policies I'm going to have
to go into uh the future so I'm going to
have another time Loop so it is for
Loops in four Loops in for Loops this
will completely explode in terms of
computational
complexity so as a result some very
clever people have written very clever
algorithms of doing this much faster
sophisticated inference branching time
active influence dynamic programming efe
our recent proposals for doing this very
clever
in the end all of these proposals come
down to a particular just a message
passing schedule
um once we commit to message passing on
the graph as our inference procedure
it's the only thing that's going on and
all of this
or sophisticated inference and granting
time active inference all it does is it
schedules the messages it says the first
this message then this message then this
message I don't mean that as a slide to
these algorithms they're very clever and
as we've seen in the presentation by
asvine Paul you get huge improvements if
you go from regular inference to
sophisticated inference but it's good to
realize that
these algorithms just specify in the
graph which message comes after which
message
um so here's an example
here's an example of a graph and a
message
um
sequence here's a message one then
message H2 and message three goes up and
then we go from FC to f f and here it
matches five and then we go to Fe and
this could correspond the sequence to
Dynamic time programming efe or
sophisticated inference
um there are a couple of problems with
this approach which we could basically
with with having the user to specify a
clever algorithm first of all
you have to be a specialist to do it
right only these are very clever people
so so that means that um if we let it
leave it to
um let's say to an engineer in a company
it's it's well it's the higher
probability is not going to get it right
that's very unfortunate
um but there's another issue and that is
that in it in a sense it's a global
variable
um in the message passing schedule all
nodes are visited because if a node
would not be visited then we shouldn't
have it in the graph and that means if
one node crashes basically the message
passing schedule is invalid I have to
reset my system
and if you fly a drone if it's deployed
and it's out in the field and a node
crashes a transistor burns out and I
have to totally reset now my system I
have to compute a new message passing
schedule
um then you're not doing inference and
you know in your drone flies into the
wall so this is not robust and it also
for very this the same reason we may
actually want to take out a node we
might we may want to prune a lot we
might want to do structural adaptation
and
we can't do structural adaptation
because we have to reset the system
recompute a message passing schedule so
this procedural style where an engineer
app purely specifies which message comes
after this message has some
disadvantages it's not very robust and
it's uh if you want to do it very clever
you have to be really a specialist so a
better system is what we call a reactive
message passing
and it's very related to what was in the
first session uh called the the actor
model Keith Duggar had a nice
presentation on the actor model
so what we will do is we will say we
will not have a global message passing
schedule the engineer will not space
specify anything anymore the inference
code that an engineer will have to write
is just say react to any free energy
minimization opportunity in other words
there is no inference code it's
completely automated
and
um we will replace This Global message
passing schedule by local triggering
inside the note so each node is now just
an autonomous autonomous system that's
interested in minimizing its free energy
uh it can do so by sending out messages
and when will it do so well it receives
messages I mean it feels when it looks
at these messages and it feels like oh
there is an opportunity for me to
minimize free energy
buy or expect the free entry by sending
out the message then will send out a
message and each node will do so by
itself asynchronously so you get
parallel distributed processing or
concurrent processing as Keys called it
um in principle you could play this game
on many uh computers at the same time uh
and so you get tremendous uh advantages
first of all you don't have to write
difficult code second of all you can do
multi-threading or you can you can run
it on multiple computers at the same
time
and so and there's also robustness
um
um uh advantages because if a note
crashes then there's nothing that stops
the system from just finding another
path right if if this node crashes this
path from here's message three at this
path Now doesn't work so I cannot send
anything to Fe anymore from uh no from X
well then I just sent a new message here
why not it's like when water
falls down a mountain and it zigzags its
way down into the value and you have
where you put up an obstruction it just
finds another path
um not the preferred path this has to
find well the the second the second best
path because the first path has been
obstructed right and that's that's
what's going to happen in this system as
well right that's just how nature works
it tries to find the best path the
easiest path and if that's not available
then we do the second best pass and
that's also what you can do with
reactive message passing so you can
prove notes you can do structural
adaptation
um and it's far more robust and you can
also get uh let's do um chance
encounters with other drones right
drones that get close can start
communicating with each other and when
they're far away they stop communicating
with each other and this is no problem
because you can basically change
who changed
um
nodes can change on the Fly who they
communicate to and who they want to
listen to and so that's that's the way
data works and also how it works when we
do a reactive
um programming area with message passing
so in summary
we're interested in automating inference
in um active influence agents right
because it's an operation that's
basically only for for experts and this
active inference technology is not going
to be successful unless you get more
people uh let's democratize it and we
get competent Engineers being able to
develop good agents right you shouldn't
have to be a top specialists in the
world to develop an active inference
agent now in order to automate
inference you must do message passing
and I've talked about that for
efficiency I've also talked about which
messages to pass
not necessarily do you have to follow
this framework but constrained better
free energy framework is very convenient
it's an umbrella framework that
basically
um
goes over all the interesting other
messages passing computations when Nas
is passing a reactiveness is passing
it's fully automated so you don't have
to write any code anymore
in principle it's come it's you can do
parallel distributed processing it's
robust to structural changes you can
learn new inference Pathways so lots of
lots of advantages here
now
how do we do it
um I'd like to introduce a toolbox that
we've been working on uh called RX infer
and we do that with my lab here at the
University I'm here in Eindhoven in the
south of the Netherlands and we have a
lab the lab is called bislab here are
postdocs and assisted professors and PhD
students and we've been working on this
for many years and some of these
um
like Albert and Ismail and thanks
um have written dissertations
and our best work we have Consolidated
that in a toolbox
and the toolbox is called RX infer and
you can if you want to have a look you
can go to the website archiver.ml
um and asking for that our confer Works
uh in the way that I've just discussed
it does message passing it tries to
minimize constraining better free energy
that means it it can come up with all
kinds of uh message passing algorithms
um it will do it in a reactive way and
they'll try to do it in real time and
low power and all the kpis that we're
talking about now it's of course not
done but um it's functional and like to
show some demos and I will
leave it to Dimitri and Bart who are two
Advanced PC students in my lab to show
the demos
so I'm gonna stop
sharing
awesome thank you great talk sure
uh can you hear me yeah yeah
okay I will try to share my screen okay
so you should see it now
looks good
okay so yeah hello uh to everyone uh I'm
uh Dimitri bag so I'm a PhD student in
bioslap and I'm from the University of
Technology uh and yes I have a small
presentation about the actual software
developments and bias lab and yeah so
all over the past few years we have
significantly improved our tools and
basically my entire PhD was dedicated to
implement the this idea which Bert was
talking about uh like implementing the
variational reactive message possible
and in this presentation I just want to
show you what you can actually do uh
using this Theory under the hood
okay so basically in order to automate
active inference right we need to
automate Bayesian influence and we have
uh we have already a lot of solutions
for that as I just Stan pyro numpyre
which is funded by Google internet is
funded by Microsoft Turing is in July
IMC and many many so uh and basically
these Solutions are really really good
so uh and they're really good at
prototyping as well our goal is
eventually to be able to deploy this
kind of systems not just prototype and
we are really focusing on this
particular properties for this ultimate
Invasion inference uh so it must be low
power adaptive real-time scalable it
also must be user friendly at the end
and it must support the large scope of
models if you want it to be useful
so and in bias lab we want to build such
a software uh with such nice properties
and it's always about Traders right so
we do something better in one particular
domain and maybe other software
libraries they might be better in a
different domain so but we are really
focusing on this particular properties
uh and so yes I will reiterate a little
bit best presentation so how do we
achieve this so we have imagine we have
an environment and we have an agent uh
and the agent allowed to take some
actions and the agent basically what he
needs is to come up with some sort of
good enough probabilistic model of its
environment
in order to do patient inference
uh and in our framework we encode the
model as a factor graph which not only
models the observations but also actions
and desired future
uh and this this approach allows us to
decompose the this complex relationships
between variables and hidden States into
some kind of structure and local blocks
uh and it's not a block it's not a black
box anymore so uh and the model itself
may have some sort of background
motivation interpretation it may encode
your prior knowledge about some
particular physical system
uh and the locality of these blocks
basically allows you to scale to
millions of variables and hidden States
it allows you to pre-optimize it maybe
or maybe use like some sort of different
approximation strategies in different
places uh so it allows a lot of very
nice properties as well
and we use reactive message passing to
run uh actual variational version
inference it uses reactive programming
under the hood to minimize the
approximation to the variation of the
energy and yes as berdos mentioned it's
it's very much related to actor model
and basically indirect transfer you can
think of different nodes as actors
themselves
uh so and they have basically one single
purpose is to send a variational message
that minimizes for energy
uh this is a very short and very high
level description but it is essentially
what is happening so we are not treating
different agents which interact with
each other as actors but we also treat
the the actual components of the
underlying model as actors themselves
it's like a very hierarchical structure
so this is the main central idea of of
this inference
uh so here for example a first example
we can do an inference in a dynamical
system and this example which is quite
old already I think it's like two years
ago so we we track a position of the
object given some noisy measurements
which are indicated by Green Dots the
actual real signal we cannot observe it
but we just can plot it uh estron is
blue and the invert signal is shown as
red and the data set is infinite the
inference and just reacts on it and does
not assume on any particular data size
simply reacts in your observation as
soon as possible
uh yeah I'm actually not sure how
smoothly Zoom shares my screen uh maybe
you can see it a bit lagging in the
animations I'm not sure because maybe
Zoom does not share it on a full frame
rate
um and also on the right hand side you
can see how we Define models uh in our
framework we use jewelry as a
programming language
and so basically this is everything that
you need to Define this particular model
and run inference on a data set and
actually I like really spend more days
to plot it instead of in France right so
inference was was an easy easiest part
from approaching was way much harder
relate to user friendliness
so and we actually have plans to improve
our model specification language make it
even easier so now for technical reasons
we have some auxiliary statements and
model specification language but we are
working to improve that and make it even
easier
uh
this is another example which is similar
to the previous one but uses much more
complex and linear dynamical system of
the double pendulum and the system is
chaotic and we can observe on this small
part of it a lot of noise also indicated
as a green dots
uh and nonetheless given
given good enough model uh you can infer
the other hidden states with pretty much
High precision and the code needed for
that is also relatively short and yeah
we also have uh examples with active
inference agents that interact with
their environment
uh so the left uh
it's left up shows uh yeah Mountain
curve problem very famous problem the
left bottom side shows an active
inference agent which tries to control
the inverted pendulum from falling in
the windy conditions the tracks and wind
we also have a demo of an agent that
controls a pendulum in an ever-changing
environment so on the right side you see
a pendulum with an engine and an engine
has engine has limited power
and the agent itself needs to reach the
goal and the goal is indicated as a red
circle so and
basically in this demo we can change the
environment in real time and see how the
agent reacts so you can change the mass
of the pendulum on its slang for the
amount of noise in the measurements or
we can change the goal we can change
maximum engine power Etc right so the
agent will still try to infer the best
possible course of actions in order to
reach its goal and it just never stops
reacting
um it's it's also actually possible to
restrict ancient power such that it will
no not longer possible to reach the goal
right but the agent would still try
uh we have other cool demos with smart
navigation and collision avoidance uh
which are still under active research
and the code for them is not available
publicly it will be soon available but
for example in this example we can
define a set of Agents with their
boundaries and a set of their
destinations so and we can see how they
try to resolve their Roots all together
um
and we can have some static obstacles in
the map we can see how agents can find
their most optimal path
in order to reach their goals and avoid
any possible Collision
and it's also not necessary to have
static obstacles uh the obstacles
themselves may move so in this demo we
have hundreds of agents that navigate
through a map of obstacles that move
from bottom to top to the circles or
obstacles and agents are depicted as
small dots and they need to go from left
to right basically avoid any sort of
pollution
uh and as I also mentioned we want to
perform efficient and real-time
inference but we also do it like low
power low performance uh on low
performance devices such as Raspberry Pi
or coolpy as an example and we have some
results of successful in running uh the
Bayesian audio Source separation for
example on cool Pi so it is actually
possible we also run active we try to
run active inference agents also on
coolpy so as the aforementioned inverted
pendulum
and
as I mentioned
we also need to have a large model scope
and basically RX infer has not been
designed to solve any of the
aforementioned problems specifically
we have a large set of different
examples in our repository different
models different data different
influence constraints
uh we have examples for linear
regression hidden Markov Model Auto
regress model hierarchy models mixture
models gaussian process and so on so
right so this approach is very versatile
and for example if you
um if you compare it with sort of a
conventional software libraries where
you let's say have a library that solves
a common filter might be a very great
Library maybe super fast have top
performance works great and very
reliable
uh it's super good but then you are
constrained by by this particular model
common filtering right and you can't
really change it much
we we are free to Define our own models
uh which we can pretty much easily
Define a model that essentially would
act equivalently to Common filtering
equation and so basically in the demo
that I showed before about object
tracking it was essentially a common
filter
that was written in a in a probabilistic
model
uh so yeah that was my small addition to
this presentation so our software is
free it's an MIT license and it's open
source available on GitHub
uh yeah and we would be happy thanks to
be able to present where we would be
happy to answer any questions thanks
awesome
awesome all right I'll just ask a quick
question in the chat
Marco asks
sorry if I missed it are the collision
avoidance demos real time adapting to
other agents Behavior or is it a
collectively pre-computed path
um so basically they are not uh super
real time they're kind of fast to
compute this path but maybe five seconds
or so but we're basically working to
make it real time so we know what is the
problem we know where to improve
and we will make it feel bad yes
almost almost like
next question do you have some
comparative data with other methods and
just more generally what kinds of
benchmarks or what when you're talking
with industry in different settings what
are people like looking for that killer
app of active inference or what are they
looking for their key measures
uh so I personally have a big paper
about the comparison with sampling based
methods like HMC and also in my PhD this
result there will be a comparison if not
also other sampling based methods uh so
long story short sampling based methods
cannot really run uh this kind of
sophisticated inference in real time
uh they're very time consuming they do
not really scale well to large problems
which is really needed for active
influences because if you have like a
large environment very complicated you
will have you will have a lot of unknown
variables in your model uh so yeah so
there is a paper that compares and
basically we show that yeah our approach
scales much much better so I personally
run on just just a regular MacBook
laptop I run the model with 2 million uh
unknown variables plus and it was like
quite quite fast and then and if
sampling based methods you may you may
find yourself in the model with like 100
variables and then you wait like two
hours or something and then it turns out
that your chain did not converge so uh
or something like that
cool yeah it's um people commenting in
the chat like how far message passing
and Factor graphs have come and so to to
bias lab and to Bert at all we
definitely
appreciate this exciting line of
research I mean there's so much to learn
there and sometimes looking at the
equations it can seem like it's like
written in stone and just sort of the
beginning and the end is you know
variational free energy but then in your
presentations you're really showing like
no we we are Hands-On that's where we
get the interpretability the modularity
that's where it really is implemented
and it's like an information Logistics
challenge it's not like an esoteric
philosophy question at that point
no no in indeed and I mean I
I should say it's uh it's taken us I
mean we're no Geniuses right so our lab
exists more than eight years and and you
see all the people in the lab it's taken
us many many many years with lots of
wrong directions to get this to work to
where it's now so it's a very long path
but the the at this moment I'm pretty
confident that at some point in the
future and I don't want to put a uh I
don't want to say in three months or one
year but it we will be able to write a
toolbox that will allow people to design
a generative model and just press a
button and and forget about the
influence you don't have to worry about
infants anymore it will be
fast and automated and that will happen
and it will happen within a few years
and uh and maybe somebody else will
write an even better toolbox but I'm
pretty confident that even our Toolbox
will be able to do that so
um and I think that yeah you know people
talk about uh so why don't we have the
success of deep learning and generative
AI right well if they have the success
because of a big data availability of
Big Data big computers and toolboxes
tensorflow and all the successes we
don't need big data because agents
collect their own data on or in the
filter we don't need big computers
active interest agents
you know they they manage their power
resources
but we need a really good toolbox
because
programming and active inference agent
programming the influence by hand is
just not doable
so we need a really good toolbox that
really automates this
we hope uh
our example will be one of the first two
boxes to do that I am sure that other
people uh will also be working on it and
and better toolboxes will come about
um but I think the the optimistic
message is that it will happen right uh
and and once we have a toolbox like that
then we can actually a large community
can start building agents and we can
actually show
uh
Deployable agents in the fields right
that they work and they work better than
the reinforcement floating agent or
whatever is out there right
um so that's I think that's a very
positive and hopeful message
it's what we expect it's what we prefer
yeah yeah yeah
any last comments from either of you
um from comments from us no no we just
I'm just very happy to uh well to get
the opportunity and uh yeah I want to uh
so yeah
um everybody can download this toolbox
um I think you at this moment you still
should be a programmer to work with the
toolbox
and I hope you're friendly because you
know it's not uh totally polished
any way that we want but it's coming
right it's coming in the next year there
will be a good toolbox for for almost
everybody to use but people that are
interested
even people that are interested to work
here at buying slab we have open
position uh for PhD students so uh um
we're happy to uh yeah to receive
emails from people that are interested
to have to work with us
thank you Dimitri anything in closing
no just that thank you yeah again for
possibility to present super nice to be
here
cool yeah well later in the year we will
be discussing your two-part recent work
and so we're going to be getting a lot
into the details and I I hope that
people in The Institute in the ecosystem
will be as excited as we all are so
thank you okay thank you bye-bye